we start here at six o'clock with
breaking news a crash on the 15 causing
a big backup there you can see the long
line of cars getting off the interstate
in the bottom right as we zoom in on
your screen southbound Lanes of the 15
at Flamingo closed right now bringing
more information as we get it now this
is not anything to do with the Tropicana
project the countdown to that is
underway right now taking a live look at
our busy freeway here in the valley of
the 15. that's actually the police
response to the crash and the Slowdown
we just showed you but the 15 is set to
shut down in less than four hours all
the way through early Monday morning